wie viele partie tatsächlich
funktionieren kann beeindruckende bilder
von der erde und warum roboter jetzt so
laufen können wie wir menschen das sind
drei der themen in den kriegs und ab -
und tickets für die photokina könnte
noch gewinnt alexander gerst
veröffentlicht beeindruckendes video wie
die erde aus den fenstern der
internationalen raumstation iss aussieht
ist eigentlich überall bekannt besonders
beeindruckende bilder wurden jetzt
allerdings vom deutschen astronauten
alexander gerst auf youtube hochgeladen
in einer ultra hohen auflösung zu sehen
sind sonnenauf und untergänge
vorbeiziehende sterne und die rotation
der erde um die eigene achse
die zeitrafferaufnahmen umfassen auch
die polarlichter stephen hawking
universum könnte kollabieren
sie locken waren vor einem kollaps
unseres universums als grund dafür sieht
er die auswirkungen der forschung am
sogenannten gottesteilchen dem explosion
vor rund zwei jahren gelangen genf der
scheinbare nachweis für das teilchen das
allen existierenden objekten form und
größe verleiht für die entdeckung nach
knapp 50 jahren forschungsarbeit
erhielten die verantwortlichen
wissenschaftler sogar den nobelpreis für
physik
der britische astrophysiker stephen
hawking mahnt jetzt aber zur vorsicht
unter extremen stressbedingungen
verursacht durch einen
teilchenbeschleuniger könnte das
teilchen einen katastrophalen vakuum
abfall bewirken
ein solches katastrophen szenario sei
aber eher unwahrscheinlich
gott sei dank denn ein
teilchenbeschleuniger der eine
ausreichende energiemenge
zusammenbringen könnte müsste größer als
die erde sein
52.000 schiffe dort ein neuer satellit
des deutschen zentrums für luft und
raumfahrt hat ihn über 660 kilometern
höhe 52.000 schiffe geordnet das
gelangen mit einer neuartigen antenne in
der form einer spiralförmigen helix
etwas länger als einen monat hat es
gedauert bis der satellit einigermaßen
stabil um die erde kreist sie jetzt
nimmt der signale von schiffen rund um
die welt auf
so lässt sich nahezu jedes schiff orten
und das gab es noch nie die etwa vier
meter lange spiralförmige helix antenne
auf dem satelliten allsat lässt einen
pegel von rund 750 kilometer durchmesser
über die erde wandern
das kennt er die einzelnen bereiche ab
und setzt sie zu einem bild zusammen
dadurch entstehen beeindruckende bilder
das im ersten monat bereits über 50.000
signale bestimmten schiffen zugeordnet
werden konnten ist eine premiere
schreibt das dlr im gegensatz zu
früheren antennen arbeitet die helix
antenne nämlich fokussierter sie
überprüft einen kleineren bereich nach
signalen und kann diese so einfacher zu
ordnen
roboter die die menschen laufen
der japanische roboter acht ihre slots
auf zwei beinen und bewegt sich dabei
wie ein mensch bis zu 42 kilometer pro
stunde schafft der kleine roboter dessen
beine ja gerade einmal so 14 zentimeter
kurzen diese geschwindigkeit entspricht
ungefähr einem flotten spaziergänger um
tatsächlich zu laufen nutzt der roboter
ein system in dem er visuelle eindrücke
verarbeitet um nicht die balance zu
verlieren nach jesus das steht für
active coordinated highspeed image
prozess in running experiment system
läuft im vergleich runder und
menschlicher als seine vorgänger war
iris ist es das sogenannte visual
feedback was für einen sicheren stand
und menschlichen gang sorgt dieses
bildverarbeitungssystem ermöglicht dem
roboter sobald er beim laufen die hüfte
nach vorne schiebt und so zunächst aus
dem gleichgewicht gerät im richtigen
moment das andere bein nach vorne zu
schnell wieder
telepathie funktioniert zum aller ersten
mal in der geschichte der menschheit ist
es forschern gelungen gedanken über eine
entfernung von mehreren tausend
kilometern hinweg zu übertragen
es ist ihnen also tatsächlich telepathie
gelungen bei diesem experiment haben die
forscher einen in indien sitzenden
probanden einfach die worte
hallo und tschüss denken lassen und die
hirnströme mit einer
elektroenzephalographie aufgezeichnet
dazu wurden der testpersonen diverse
magnet elektroden am kopf befestigt die
aufgenommenen hirnströme wurden dann in
einen binärcode umgewandelt und per mail
an kollegen in frankreich verschickt
iris binärcode das ist die
computersprache besteht nur aus nullen
und einsen daraus werden quasi alle
programme bilder texte und so weiter
gemacht
in frankreich angekommen wurde der code
wieder übersetzt aber diesmal als
lichtblitze die am rande des sichtfeldes
eines weiteren probanden zu sehen waren
diesen prozess bezeichnen die forscher
als transkranielle magnetstimulation das
erstaunliche dabei ist der proband in
frankreich hatte keine ahnung an welche
worte sein gegenüber in indien gedacht
hatte
trotzdem konnte er sie verstehen und
sogar flugzeuge können schon mit
gedanken gesteuert werden in diesem
video könnt ihr sehen wie das
funktioniert hier klicken oder den link
in der video beschreibungen täglich
wissenschaftlers gibt es im blog unter
app dafür hier klicken oder eben in der
video beschreibung und was meint ihr
wird telepathie bald vielleicht
alltäglich diskutiert ist wie immer mit
mir in den kommentaren und produktiver
tickets habe ich vergessen 2 x 2 tickets
gibt es für die messe und eine online
video session mit mir und geht für
diejenigen die an pixum merry mail.com
mailen und zwar wie viele schiffe vom
neuen satelliten geortet worden
bei mehreren richtigen antworten
entscheidet wie markt das los bis dann
bleibt